[Driving synth beat]
- [Allen Robinson:] Whether it's playoff time,
first game of the season,
whatever it is, you know,
you throw the ball,
Imma come down with it.
- [Adam Lefkoe:] This is it, No. 10.
Stunner. To the corner!
Got it.
- [Robinson:] Man, I'm sweating my butt off.
Madden, you better up my rating.
[Upbeat music]
- Hey, everybody. Welcome to
another episode of "Underrated."
I'm your host, Adam Lefkoe.
If you've watched football
for the last half decade,
it should not surprise
you that Allen Robinson
has some top-flight Madden ratings.
And if you've seen
commercials during that time,
you probably also know that State Farm
has surprisingly great rates.
Back to Allen Robinson.
We gotta get those ratings higher,
and I got a Madden ratings
adjuster to talk to.
Hey, Jake. Get Madden on the phone.
- Calling Madden ratings adjuster.
- [Lefkoe:] Mr. Oldenburg, I presume.
Not wasting any time.
Allen Robinson, do you agree
with me he's underrated?
- I mean, it's possible he
could be underrated.
He has played with some, not
always the best quarterbacks.
- I'm glad you understand that.
We don't even have to say their names.
Let's call up Allen Robinson.
Hey, Jake. Call best
friend, Allen Robinson.
- Calling Allen Robinson.
- [Lefkoe:] Allen Robinson. Only,
I don't know, the most underrated
wide receiver in the NFL.
How ya doin', pal?
- I'm good, man. How you doing, Adam?
- [Lefkoe:] Honestly, I'm a little annoyed.
I was looking at your Madden ratings
and I saw where they had you.
And as a very good friend,
I cannot let that slide,
but I am here to fix it.
Allen, this is Clint Oldenburg.
He is the Madden ratings adjuster.
Clint, what would you like to say to Allen?
- Ooh, Allen Robinson, one
of my favorite players.
What do you got for me today?
I like Allen a lot.
- [Lefkoe:] All right, well, let's
get into the numbers here.
First one. No one talks about it.
Stamina. I mean, look at
this collection of 90s.
We've got jumping, acceleration,
heck, even awareness,
which means they think
that you're really smart.
I just have no idea
why stamina isn't there
with everything else.
- I have no idea either.
- [Lefkoe:] On Madden, I've seen it:
Your character is bent
over huffin' and puffin'
and ready to come out.
Clint, second one: spectacular catches.
I've seen this dude catch
balls off the helmet.
What do I do to get that up?
- Spec catch. Popular rating.
Simply put, you gotta make amazing happen.
We gotta see these, you know, wow
moments that occur in Madden.
Gotta see those in real life.
- Whether it's playoff time,
first game of the season,
college, whatever it is, you know,
you throw the ball,
Imma come down with it.
- Make amazing happen.
Clint, I'll talk to you soon.
[Upbeat music]
- [Lefkoe:] So, Allen, I've seen you play.
You wear down corners.
You're not the one getting worn down.
So what we're gonna do is
a bit of a hurry-up offense.
We're gonna start on the 5,
and if you can outlast
your Madden character,
I think we can get the stamina
rating bumped up big time.
- Sounds good.
- [Lefkoe:] So we have assembled
this fine team right here.
Together, you'll quickly
march down the field.
No timeouts.
No rest.
We are upping my man's ratings today.
- Most definitely. Let's get it done.
- [Lefkoe:] Sweat is already
drippin'. I love it.
All right, here we go, Allen.
Ooh. Up. Stop.
Good catch.
All right. Let's get going.
No stopping.
You got this, baby.
Another one. Up. In.
Oooh, made him get down and
get it on that one too.
- [Offscreen:] Same play.
- [Lefkoe:] Snap to the quarterback.
Allen.
Caught it. Turnin' upfield.
The Bears are moving the chains.
Up. In.
That one was high.
Incomplete pass.
Ooh, he's got a run block.
By the way, it is really hot there.
And I am in air conditioning, so...
[Robinson breathing]
- [Lefkoe:] Dime. We're good.
[Intense music]
- [Lefkoe:] This is where
his Madden character
would start huffin' and puffin'.
Now, slant, caught, movin' the chains.
- [Offscreen:] Same play that you just did.
Pace, pace.
- [Lefkoe:] Throwin' it. Nice.
Did he get in the end zone?
No, just down there at the 1.
This is it. No. 10.
Stunner. To the corner.
Got it!
How are you feelin', man?
That looked exhausting.
- I feel great, man. I got 10 more in me.
Let's go, Madden, boost that stamina up.
- And, I mean, you ended it
with the perfect touchdown, A-Rob.
- Man, gotta end it with a
little spectacular catch action, you know?
- You must have read my mind.
How would you feel about
making a highlight reel of you
recreating five iconic NFL catches?
- [Robinson:] Sounds good to me.
[Upbeat music]
- [Lefkoe:] So who are you thinking first?
- Let's do the Randy Moss one first.
- Now you're talkin', my man.
The 2010 one-hander against
Revis. Let's see it.
[Intense music]
Is that Allen Moss?
[Ding]
Or is that Randy Robinson?
All right. We got that one down.
- [Robinson laughing]
- That one felt great. So
who're you thinking next?
- Let's do Dwight.
- OK, classic. "The Catch"
for the 1981 NFC championship.
If you can give me all 42
inches of your vertical,
I think it's over.
[Ding]
- What's your thoughts, Adam?
- I think every time you go up for a ball,
it's comin' down with Allen Robinson.
- Most definitely. That's
what I like to hear.
- So next would be…?
- Let's go Santonio.
- [Lefkoe:] Ooh, one of my favorites.
Santonio Holmes in the
end zone in the Super Bowl.
Show me how it's done.
[Intense music]
- Ooh, bro, you went horizontal.
- [Robinson:] I think that's the one, man.
[Ding]
- I think that was the one for sure.
All right. Add it to the highlight.
So the last one is Odell, and
this one's a little crazy.
- [Robinson:] That was my rookie year.
And I remember thinking,
like, that might—not might be,
that probably to this day the
craziest catch I've actually seen.
- So I think if we give it
our best three attempts,
I drop the most
impressive one on the reel,
and I'll send that to Madden.
- I can do that. I can do that.
- I don't know about you guys,
but I feel a surprisingly great
spectacular catch comin' on.
[Intense music]
[Buzz]
- [Lefkoe:] Too high, man.
You gotta keep it down a little bit,
but I like the idea.
[Intense music]
- [Lefkoe:] Ah.
[Buzz]
Here we go. Everything on the line.
Man, let her rip.
Takes the snap.
Fires, throws,
and he hits it! Wow.
[Ding]
Add it to the highlight.
EA Sports: in for a heck of a delivery.
So, Allen, we showed the stamina.
We showed the spectacular catches.
Do you think we did enough for
the ratings adjuster today?
- Man, I'm sweatin' my butt off.
Madden, you better up my rating.
- And if they don't move,
I'm gonna get you on
the phone with the adjuster,
and we're gonna take
care of this man to man.
- Sounds good, man. I appreciate it.
- All right, we'll get it
done, man. You got my word.
[Upbeat music]
Clint, I have not seen an athlete
get this sweaty for ratings before.
The video looks great.
What did you think of
it? It better be good.
- There was some work
being done on this video.
- I hope you reward him.
I'm bringing him on now.
You're gonna have to
talk to him face to face.
Let's call up Allen Robinson.
Eyyy, there he is. Big 12.
Clint, you looked at the tape.
Spectacular catch and stamina.
What did you think about
those two drills when you're
watching on tape?
- Obviously, great drills.
I really liked how you made
him go through a 10-play drive.
That was phenomenal.
- OK, explain that.
- [Oldenburg:] So going up two
points in stamina from 89 to 91
from the 24th-rated wide
receiver in stamina,
now at 15th place for wide receivers.
And he's passed some, you know, amazing players
like A.J. Green and Adam
Thielen in that area.
- You went from a B-plus to an A-minus.
- Gotta keep just movin' 'em on up.
- [Oldenburg:] All right, spec catch, Allen,
you're gonna get a one-point upgrade.
[Ding]
You're going from 94 to 95.
So you're going from the
10th-best wide receiver to
you're now tied for the
eighth-best wide receiver
in spec catch.
- 95 is a hard A. Clint.
- Top eight, top eight.
- OK.
- That's good news. That's good news.
That's what we worked for, man.
That's why we went out on the field.
- And now the big question:
Is Allen Robinson underrated?
- In the NFL world, Allen
Robinson is absolutely the most
underrated player in the NFL.
From a Madden standpoint,
Allen Robinson is a little bit underrated.
- Allen, overall,
how does it feel to know
that you were underrated?
- You know, I think it's fun. You know,
I don't ever think I've
started the year off at a 90,
so I really take pride in, you know,
seeing how those drills paid off.
- I love it when a good
plan comes together
and it ends up being surprisingly great.
And this has been a surprisingly
great episode of "Underrated"
brought to you by the
surprisingly great rates
of State Farm.
Allen, you're the man, dude.
[Energetic music]